hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Ione let's go okay
was expecting something to pop out there
but nothing dead okay so we're fine but
there's this weird bathtub full of black
liquid wonder what that's all about
probably not what did I just do
I found Philips head screwdriver
that's good I guess okay so in here can
i wet the handkerchief which is
something that I wanted to do please
please can I please can I eat it okay so
that's nothing I could have just dipped
it in the table while I was there but no
I gotta be a stupid bumping idiot
so whatever okay so this is open to I
found the item soap maybe I can use that
to clean the blood off lift it up the
toilet I don't have to go is there gonna
be some butt stabber that comes up
behind me and stab it in the lot this
time okay don't look at the commuter
yeah sorry goodie stuff okay let's get
out of here
hmm okay so what do I do with this ah
we're dug up up oh no I went the wrong
way no that's bad is it bad is it bad
I didn't made out I'm sorry ah I think
out sweet moves bro I can't believe that
actually worked
oh my god I can't believe it that
get out of here get out of here get out
of here get out here get out of you're
gonna wait the music stop did he stop
chasing me
hahaha I did it I am random I'm pro I'm
so pro I'm too proud you dare I say I
might need to pro know who knows these
things okay so anyway now that I got
this up I'm gonna try to once again
fruitlessly wash this blood off because
I have a feeling that something is going
on here so pour soap on the handkerchief
yes that's what you need to do do that
thing hankerchief now I've wiped the
piano with a handkerchief and yeah I
know it I knew that would happen okay so
I got a correspond up to the safe so
it's six seven nine yeah so six is Z
hahaha Wow where'd you come from good
honor no no no no no bro no what did you
come from you son of a [ __ ] get out of
here yeah and you know ah one of these
days is this hiding those Heinie's
waters not gonna work one of these days
oh what's that
you're too big dumb and slow to find me
oh oh
who's too Pro I am I am from now on
every enemy in every game I play is
gonna be the crazed but snapper and you
are no different okay six seven nine so
the one to the left is six seven nine oh
they're upside down um
okay seven is a middle one if you flip
them around but hang on
what okay seven is the second one this
is definitely seven those are upside
down so it would be if that one if that
was wait what about that one right there
that looks like the the nine one there
weren't four keys what is going on here
wait hang on six lose something seven
that looks like the one four nine sews
what what this doesn't make any sense
hang on let me I need to go back to the
679 what why you have to do this to me
I'm trying to figure out your puzzle
here and it's not working okay if we
think about this logically the one that
looks like the only ones that one was
upside down
well three of them were upside down and
then oh my god so it's some combination
of six seven and nine and then one other
number that I don't know how am I
supposed to solve this he doesn't make
any sense
ah okay all right so this one's
definitely 7 that's the only one that I
actually know um this one does look like
the 9 so I'm gonna guess that's a 9 is
this 6 upside down is this 6 upside down
are they both 6 is 1 9 9 oh my god I'm
gonna be here forever oh my god
this is how I die that one's definitely
6 that one's 9
oh I don't know all I'm gonna notice six
nine nine six seven six nine not I think
that one's definitely nine I don't know
what the hell those are what what those
in another huh I totally guessed I did
I always are yeah ah raw guessing yeah I
shouldn't be this excited about this but
yeah yeah got it
oh yeah I get it
ha ha ha suck on that monster alright
kids bedroom key on the second floor oh
yeah yeah
oh hi how'd you get in here wait a
minute wait a minute here ocean ha ha I
forgot my name was that silly you're OK
where are the others I don't know we got
separated oh really
come with me are you kidding me I'm not
walking around this mansion with that
monster loose ok fine be that way [ __ ]
go home good going gum just try to help
you okay is there something magical
under the chair no okay I did that wrong
there's something on the top of that I
see something up on the top of that
shelf over there since you're not gonna
help me blue girl OOP got it found the
item lighter fluid
awesome get off the chair throw that
lighter fluid on in there fill the
lighter with lighter fluid uh yeah okay
so now what do I do about that
do I do can I burn this maybe can I
unscrew this maybe okay there's got to
be something that I can unscrew but I
don't know what the nor knob the
doorknob I can unscrew the doorknob hell
yeah
on the door up here that goes to nowhere
it's the only one with an actual knob
anyway
ha oh I thought you were an enemy
hiroshima you're okay how are you okay
yeah I guess her ocean did you see it
too
that monster of course I saw it it was
giant and purple how could I miss it
it's so unbelievable to think that a
creature like that exists all the exits
are blocked were trapped in here it
would seem so let's split up and look
around I'll check the first floor I've
already checked the vert floor you might
not want to go down there good luck
you're gonna need it buddy what he's
stabbing me I bought ah okay anyway so
carrying on to what I was doing got it
found the atom doorknob sweet cuz I'm so
amazing - amazing
I'm just waiting cuz I know he's gonna
pop out at any many days ago hey hey
buddy hey friend how are you you guys
look good there's no knob so I can't
open the door I don't think there's a
door there I think it's crazy
here we go anyway it is dark in here
you'd let it oh good golly I said no no
no thank you I don't want it what do I
did it
hang on is there anything else things I
need like a giant person what if it was
like just just a purple monster sitting
in the corner waiting for me to walk
over it
I would [ __ ] myself dry I would
absolutely lose all control of the house
how is this good why am I going into a
prison is that actually something or
that was just dust on my screen why is
this good who was just cool ah what the
hell I want to do anything
is that what the hell hi what am I
supposed to do
what the hell what am I supposed to do
if I gotta burn it pick it up with this
chart oh ok those way obvious I'm
terribly sorry about that ha whoa what
now Oh huh huh oh yeah yeah that's right
hi let's get on there friend hi nice
hands yeah you're not getting through
here
you ain't nice booty are you naked it
would appear that you are naked yeah
that's right get out of your golf car my
friends cuz they're much easier prey
than I am apparently hello oh it's dark
in here I forgot how like waiting for
something to happen okay oh if that blue
bastard is just like sticking around
that's new yeah okay was that they're
always I don't think that was always
there that's a lie that's just a dirty
lie that was not there before
okay when's he gonna pop out again
randomly beeping yeah there we go going
down into the basement okay gotta go up
and find Mika where was Mika
where is Mika where the hell is my guide
Oh in the children's room that's right
the kid's room Oh what are you doing her
oh don't do it tomato
don't tell me about ah come on I knew
that was gonna stop working once or
twice Oh
what was he doing to her what kind of
demented freak is he he's a son of a
[ __ ] that's what he is
what was he doing the way he looked at
me like just like I'm gonna get you huh
yeah that's seemed iike this is why you
should have followed me so where am I
gonna go if that hiding spot doesn't
work anymore
was there one upstairs I liked I think
there was also a hiding spot upstairs so
I'm gonna I'm gonna try that hey buddy
leave her alone look just the way that I
is suddenly like no oh oh I couldn't
even get to it okay I don't know what
I'm supposed to do to get away from this
guy now but uh apparently I'm screwed
I'm going to the basement screw you
buddy I'm going to the basement that's
where I was really intending to go in
there go I'm going right now ah I'm in
the basement what are you gonna do now
you gonna do things to me ha ha ha oh no
no no oh you son of a [ __ ] okay
so apparently when I got to do this I
got a dip duck dive no dodge dip dive
and dodge and somehow I'll get around
him and he's not going to do things to
me when I'm dead
and I'm a horrible just mangled death
corpse he's obviously gonna exploit me
which is not good go away man go away oh
there was something on the thing there I
saw a glowing day it's all glowy dewy
closet closet no no can't go in the
closet and darken our attack a nap ah
man oh man what am I supposed to oh I
know how to lose him I'll drop down in
the hole
that's what I'll do you come at me bro
yeah you don't give me the stick I
prologue give you something turn I'll
give you what there's a whoosh oh wow
that's hardly fair
what oh oh yeah dick moves I'm gonna do
that again did you wait ah ha ha got you
lost your sock on there hmm yeah for me
Myka Myka though for Myka what Avenue
I'm gonna like looking here Mangala
Forbes uh poor girl she's just dead I
don't have any commentary about that
yeah alright then
oh that sucks I guess so man here we go
what's up here well I can't reach that I
need to find something to stand on in
order to be able to get up there
apparently maybe we could push this
chair out and there's something up there
too and let me try to push this chair
all the way out there don't know if I
can't hang on let me look first let me
see if I can get something up here ah
found the item flat head screwdriver
flat head screwdriver are you just
calling me insulting names to try now
man I push this out side there we go
alright it actually worked I didn't know
if that was gonna go cool
cool beans bruh
oh I may have done that wrong nope I got
it I found the item basement jail cell
key ah
what ow wha what we're dad daddy what
you turn it in it you were a thingy oh
that's not good
I'm gonna do the same thing I did before
except somehow I'm gonna do it better
I'm gonna do it better get out of here
Wow that's not fair I'm gonna lose you
around the piano oh ah ha ha yeah yeah
yeah
what now what huh don't need to look at
that what now or now I'm getting cocky
I'm getting cocky but that's what I do
that's how I'll be here me myself and I
gonna do great so that was Mika right
that was Mika who had been dabbling
a big monster and I'm assuming there's
some sort of werewolf thing well I'll
turn into a giant purple monster okay
that door is locked
it's apparently really dark in here so I
gotta use my lighter
totally awesome by the way totally
awesome
totally awesome there we go there we go
ooh hi I'm gonna close this door thank
you very much good - um not do you be
[ __ ] I'm gonna write that down cuz that's
probably important yeah
all right we got some sort of a tea with
a Korean M on the bottom let's see we
could Japanese word for douche side
there and big blue douche I'm pretty
sure that's what it spells out big blue
douche was here that's right okay so I
got the symbols I don't know what they
mean but I wrote him down and I summoned
a demon into my house no no that's
probably what I did though just sayin
just sayin
okay what the that's weird I gotta write
that down too
okay so there's some sort of symbols
there I'm hesitant to leave this place
cuz I have a feeling okay just checking
I've been hurt before I've been hurt
before so what do I do now what wait
what items do I have I have a flathead
and switch the head of the driver
I guess what is he gonna do what does
that do I have no idea what am I
supposed to do with the Flathead I
haven't seen anything that I can use it
on as opposed to anything else oh good
yeah hide in the closet
well I'm out of time anyway so this was
a good place to stop as XO thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
then and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye
Oh
everything looks awesome
previously that looked amazing